it is time right now for what's trending
with las vegas now host mercedes
martinez as you can see
she's in the mix 941 studios right now
mercedes good morning to you how you
doing this fine friday hi mercedes good
morning
my favorite friday we
begin with victoria's secret
their famous angels are no more
they are being replaced by a group of
seven
notable women instead now they're trying
for a rebrand and they're doing away
with the angels in an
attempt to redefine what is sexy great
idea
some of the women include soccer star
megan repino
priyanka chopra jonas and trans model
valentina sampao
now one thing though social media has a
lot to say about it both for
and against the move but the majority of
people are upset
because of the lack of size
representation
now to former las vegas headliner
britney spears well
yesterday during an instagram video
where she was answering
fan questions britney said she doesn't
know
if she'll ever perform again britney
said quote
i have no idea i'm having fun right now
i'm in a transition in my life
and i'm enjoying myself she has not been
on stage in years her second residency
ended before it even began all because
she's in the midst
of a battle over her conservatorship now
for the first time in years brittany's
going to actually speak directly to the
court
in la on wednesday so that should be
very interesting it's going to be via
video but this is
the first time we'll hear from her john
alex yeah last time i remember seeing
her was
when she had that announcement at park
mgm i think it was when she was supposed
to start her residency there and then it
just
yeah never happened all right let's talk
about cinnabun mercedes which
i know distracts me when i'm at mccarran
airport
it's not the healthiest thing it's kind
of covered in everything we're not
supposed to have
but they're going to make it more
healthy yeah what's going on
we don't want to be more healthy sort of
it's don't get too excited so what
they're doing is they're rolling out
a new protein drink later this month i
know it sounds weird cinnabon protein
drink
but it's supposed to taste just like the
real thing minus
the baked goodness so the drink it's
going to have 10 grams of protein
21 vitamins and only 240 calories
an actual cinnabon has about 900
calories
now they're also debuting a bunch of
cereal flavored
protein drinks earlier this year there's
a fruit loops protein drink
a golden grams one and frosted flakes
in your protein drink okay but hang on a
second
missing i think in those statistics is
the amount of sugar in it yeah i feel
like that's all the charts
so is it going to be like a flavored
coffee kind of thing mercedes do we know
no it's like a the carnation instant
breakfast brand that's putting it out
oh okay just in a little bottle and you
can chug it
before you guys head on the air and feel
like you were at the airport eating that
cinnamon
yes and then crash then drive all your
your
friends on the plane craze while you're
sitting there crushing a cinnabon while
they're just
trying to get some some sleep yeah yeah
that's the way to make some dreams
i take the cinnabon person in the state
next to me
more so than the person that gets a
sandwich with the onions on it oh my god
yes or the person who you hear every
chip it's like
they every tiny chip you hear it coming
out of the bag
freaking nuts okay mercedes thank you so
much you have a great weekend